PABLO CAIF: Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming
to my presentation.
This presentation is about
a story of an Australian ISP
and how they were trying to
deal with their big data,
and how we, with
a very small team,
were able, by using
BigQuery and Dataflow,
to help them to finally get
useful insights out of it.
So I'm going to tell you a
little bit more about myself
first.
So I didn't mention before,
my name is Pablo Caif.
I'm a software engineer.
I've been in the industry
a bit longer than 13 years.
And I work for
Shine Technologies.
Shine Technologies is
a consultancy company
based in Melbourne,
Australia, or Down
Under as you call it here.
And we basically help customers.
And one of our customers,
the customer of this story,
is Telstra.
I'm also a Google
Developer expert
for the Google Cloud Platform.
And although I come
from Australia,
I'm sorry to tell
you it's not going
to be an Australian accent
here, because I'm originally
from Argentina.
So plenty of
Spanish accent here.
So let's talk a little
bit about Telstra.
So Telstra, it's one of the
largest ISP and mobile operator
in Australia.
They own most of
the mobile network
and the actual telephone
network in Australia.
And they provide services
like home internet
access, mobile access, and
broadband access as well.
And they have a lot of
accounts, customers.
Between home internet access
and mobile access and stuff
like that, they have more
than 20 million accounts.
And if we take into
account that people
in Australia, the population
is just 24 million,
that's a fair share.
They're a very large company.
They have more than
32,000 employees.
And they make a lot of money.
But there is something
particular about them,
which is that they have
a lot of data to process.
So all of the stuff that
I'm going to tell you
is actually about
a smaller business
unit of Telstra, which
is Telstra Media.
And they are a big
digital publisher.
And what they do is they
own several very high
profile websites in Australia.
And as many as you
might now, in Australia,
we like sports quite a lot.
So two of these websites are
the AFL, the Australian Football
League, and the NRL, the
National Rugby League.
And these websites, especially
when they're in season
and games are being played
and stuff like that,
you can imagine people are
constantly checking the results
and stuff like that.
So they get a lot of traffic.
So around 5,000 requests per
second, which is quite a lot.
And also if you would
imagine the websites,
they have the central space
with all the information,
stuff the would be of interest.
But they also have
digital real estate, space
that they take up advantage of.
So what do they do
with this space?
They put lots and lots of ads.
So what they do with
these ads is basically
use targeted advertising
to generate revenue.
And this targeted
advertising, it's
basically through
basic demographics,
which means that we have
several data points.
The way they are
able to serve the ads
is using DoubleClick
for Publishers, or DFP,
as an ad server.
And every time an
ad is being shown,
that's what we
call an impression.
Or someone clicks on an ad,
that we get a log entry.
And that log entry contains a
lot of very interesting data
points that we can use.
And they make a lot of
actually information out of it.
So imagine, 15,000
requests per second
hitting our page, our web pages.
If we were to try to
collect all this stuff,
it would turn into 5 billion
impressions per month,
or something around
three terabytes per month
of information.
Just to put it in perspective,
the age of our sun
is 4.5 billion years.
So to put everything
into context,
it was the year 2007,
almost 10 years ago.
And our customer Telstra,
they say, why don't we
start getting some
useful information out
of all these logs, all this
stuff we keep generating?
But they found
out that it wasn't
that easy to do back
at that time using DFP,
because imagine
business people trying
to generate these reports.
It was time consuming.
The stuff that we're
trying to find out,
it was very difficult to find
in such a large amount of data.
And whenever they were able
to get anything out of it,
it took them a long time.
And one of the things that they
were finding a bit limiting
was also there wasn't any
out of the box visualizations
that they could use.
So they call us and they
say, can you help us?
So we'd been working
with them before.
And we decided to
assemble a team.
So this business unit of Telstra
is a relatively independent
business unit.
They have their own budget.
And they can do
certain innovation.
So we assembled a team,
just two engineers, one BA,
and that was all we had.
So we said OK, how we
can tackle this problem?
So we tried to
analyze all this data.
And what we did, what anyone
would do back in 2007,
tried to put it
in data warehouse,
in Oracle instances
using servers,
like renting our own servers,
rack and stack infrastructure,
which a lot of headaches,
of course, because it wasn't
really easy to get a-- every
time we wanted a new server,
it could take six months to get
it approved, and then another
maybe three months
until we finally
would get the actual server.
And then configuration
and stuff like that, which
takes time and is expensive.
The amount of data was
such a huge amount of data
that we were only able to
look and analyze just the 10%.
Imagine trying to run
queries on an Oracle instance
like data warehouse
and stuff like that.
And it turned out that it was
very costly for this business
unit.
And one of the major
problems they had
is every time we were
getting more data,
it was hard to scale.
As I said before,
getting a new sever,
waiting six to eight months
to get it actually in,
and even paying for some
stuff that we might not
be using all the time.
So at a very high level, this
is how our solution looked like.
So we had the request
come into our web pages.
And we were using,
as I mentioned
before, Double Click for
Publishers to serve the ads.
And we were importing
all these logs
and trying to put them
in these data warehouses.
But things didn't really
work as we expected.
We ended up a little
bit like this,
putting out fires all the time.
So you can see the two
engineers and the BA.
So things like running out
of space on the database,
having to contact DBAs
to resize tablespaces,
having hard drives breaking
down and someone calling us
and telling us, look,
your old data, you
are not going to be able to use
all this data until probably
two, three days until we recover
all the backups and everything
is back online.
It wasn't really easy.
So we came to realize that we
were caring too much about all
this infrastructure.
It was a huge [INAUDIBLE]
for us to try to take it
off all the situations.
But we really wanted to get
results out of all this data.
That was all we really cared.
So back in 2007, we found
ourselves in a dead end.
Moving this data from DFP to
our internal infrastructure
was very difficult and
it took a long time.
We saturated all the networks
because of all the traffic
we were generating.
So we were constantly getting
calls and people annoyed
because everything
was running slow.
And trying to run queries over
such a huge amount of data,
it was really, really slow.
And I'm not talking
about minutes or hours.
It might take days.
We might just kick off the
query, come back the next day
and hope that it
will actually finish.
Sometimes it might
just crash and we
would have to contact DBAs so
they could tune the database
a little bit more.
So back in 2007, this part
was really, really big for us.
And we didn't really
know what to do.
So we found ourselves
drowning in all this data,
but trying desperately to
get insights out of it.
So a long time after that, we
basically put these in a drawer
or on a back burner as
we say in Australia.
2012, several
years later, things
have changed quite a lot.
So Google was offering
cloud services.
And this is what they were
offering back in 2012.
And we hear about a few things--
App Engine, Cloud Storage.
But we noticed something
very interesting there,
which was BigQuery.
So with the other engineer
we started our research
and saying, well what
is BigQuery thing?
I'm sure you've heard quite
a lot about BigQuery already.
This is the second day
actually of GTP Next.
But just going to tell you what
was very interesting for us.
So it's analytics as a service.
And this was a very important
point for us-- no ops.
So stop worrying about
infrastructure and problems
and situations like that.
We didn't need to think
about installing BigQuery
anywhere or setting up
clusters or configuring
things or anything of that.
Just create an account,
put in the data,
and querying the data.
It was able to scale
to petabytes, which
is what we were looking for.
And it has a SQL interface.
So as I mentioned before,
we were using Oracle.
We were familiar with SQL.
It was perfect for us.
We could just pretty
much use the same syntax
and get the data out.
And it's really, really fast.
So wonder ourselves,
can we actually
use this BigQuery tool
to solve all this problem
we were having back in 2007?
So we removed the dust
off of the whole problem,
took it out, and
started thinking.
And we found out
that it was possible,
there was a way of
solving this problem.
So we were able to get all
this logs, ad serving logs
from DoubleClick for Publishers
and put them in cloud storage.
And since with BigQuery
it is very easy
to import data directly
from cloud storage getting
CSV files, we put
everything in BigQuery.
And then we
connected to Tableau.
And we were finally able
to get the insights out.
So all of these
impossible things
we couldn't achieve before, all
of the sudden became possible.
We were able to move the data
extremely fast because we were
within the same infrastructure.
We didn't need to download
that as we were doing before.
We stopped worrying so much
about the infrastructure.
No more calling DBAs.
No more breaking networks or
broke down servers and stuff
like that.
Our costs exponentially reduced.
And these long
hours or maybe days
hoping that a query would
finish all of a sudden
turned into seconds.
Just imagine seconds to
get your results out.
And this allowed
our customer Telstra
to get extremely fast time
to get their insights out
of all these logs.
And other very
interesting things
we found using
BigQuery were it was
great for doing ad hoc reports.
So I remember once a
DBA came to me and said,
I'm about to go to a
very important meeting
with the stakeholders,
and I need
to query around two or
three years worth of data.
Can you do it?
Yes.
I just sit there,
wrote some SQL.
There you go.
As I mentioned before, very
easy to move the data from DFP
to BigQuery because it was all
within Google infrastructure.
And we were using Java.
We are still using Java for
most of the stuff we do.
So it was very natural
for us to use the SDK.
So as you might now, BigQuery
has an SDK in Java, Python,
and a few other languages.
So we're using the Java SDK.
And it was really
cost effective for us.
But how cost effective?
So if you just try to
calculate paying for DBAs,
paying for your servers,
paying for people looking
after the whole
infrastructure, I
don't think you can get it for
any less than, I don't know,
$40, $50k per moth.
For us, it ended up
being just $1,500
per month per 100 terabytes.
Preach it.
So I'm going to tell
you a few things
we learned when we were
using BigQuery that I'd
like to share with you.
One very interesting thing
we found that was the cache.
So it was very useful
for us to save money.
So BigQuery allows you to cache
the result of the queries.
So when you're running
a query, if you
display the query
options and take that,
use the cache results, it will
basically cache the results.
And next time you run the
query, you won't pay for that.
So this here is an example.
This query will
process 11.5 gigabytes.
So when it runs, it
takes two seconds.
And as I tell us
before, it actually
processed 11.5 gigabytes.
But when we run it
the second time,
you can see that the results
just come from the cache.
So you don't pay to
process that data again.
Another very useful thing we
found was the table decorators.
Table decorators allow you to
get a snapshot of your data.
And it's very
useful for when you
have a table where
you're constantly
streaming information in.
So for example,
this table, if I do
SELECT *, which is not a
recommended thing to do,
it's going to
process-- I'm going
to go through 460 gigabytes.
And if I put the table decorator
just to restrict the last hour,
you see how it gets drastically
reduced to 67 megabytes.
Another thing we
found very useful
was the idea of start
with small data sets.
So when you're
writing your queries
and you're trying to figure out
how you want to have your SQLs
and you want to join to several
tables and stuff like that,
it's always a good idea to
save the data to a small table,
like just maybe 1,000 rows,
100,000 or something like that.
So you can see
here, for example,
if I was to play with this
table, for example, just
doing that would
process 11.5 gigabytes.
However, if I save
only 1,000 records,
the table gets reduced
to 38 kilobytes,
which is completely different.
And this is the the
last step for BigQuery.
Another thing we
found very useful
is as we were using
BigQuery, it's very easy
to forget tables along the way.
So you play with tables,
you get several gigabytes
worth of data in tables.
So anything is
actually used, the Time
to Live feature, that it can
also be used in data sets.
But here's an example on the
table when using the Java SDK.
So just set at expiration time.
In this case it's just a minute.
And once you apply the change,
the table will be removed.
So it's very good when you're
having temporary tables, again
just set an expiration time.
And I just want to reiterate,
just two engineers.
That was the team.
So we decided to move to
the next stage, right?
We had all this stuff going,
getting all the logs from DFP.
And we say, why not
try in real time?
We immediately started seeing
a few very interesting things
about it.
So one thing will
be the campaign
managers would be able to get
very good feedback about how
their ads were going.
And as a consequence
of that, they
would be able to modify if
maybe they weren't targeting
the right demographics.
They wanted to change
something, they
were able to change
it on the fly.
And that allowed the business
to actually move with it
and make decisions as the
things were actually happening,
not after they happened.
And this batch
processing we were
doing before, of taking data
out of DFP, it was great.
But it was running every night.
And it had a slow
turn around time.
And a very interesting thing
for us was the wow factor.
So imagine seeing a map
of Australia, a heat
map with different
points where you're
getting your impressions
by geolocation
and distributing the
population or maybe showing
if it was tablet,
desktop, or mobile phones.
So we decided to use
the streaming stuff
that BigQuery has.
So BigQuery has a streaming API.
And the way we implemented
this was creating
a very simple JavaScript
tag that it was basically
just pinging one very
simple sever app.
And every time someone
was seeing an ad
or maybe besieging the
website, that was directly
pinging our server.
That way impressions
and clicks were directly
streaming to BigQuery.
And in order to being able to
see results much more easily
and save money, we we're
using table decorator
so we could reduce the threshold
of data we were querying.
So maybe just have
the last 10 minutes
so you could see
much bigger changes.
And then we built a
dashboard using D3.
D3 is a JavaScript library
for doing graphs and stuff
like that.
And this is how
our solution looked
at a very, very high level.
So as I mentioned before,
we had the requests
hitting our severs.
We deploy our app to App Engine.
And then we were streaming
every single request
with all this log information
directly to BigQuery.
And here is a demo
of part of the app.
So let me show you how it works.
So what you can see
there is each dot
is several impressions actually
in that geographic zone,
geographic area.
And you can see
there how we actually
are splitting the whole
amount, the total impressions,
by state in Australia.
And we're also getting
an average of impressions
per minute and splitting
it between mobile, tablet,
and online.
Online will be the desktop.
So let's move back
to the slides.
Again, just two engineers.
That was the team,
just two of us.
OK, so feels like that
went really interesting.
We were able to, first, analyze
all this amount of data,
process it, and get insight
immediately using BigQuery,
and then have this
streaming thing going on.
And the business
started realizing
how powerful BigQuery was.
So they engaged data scientists.
And what they wanted to do
is to alter the distribution
in the sample set to be more
representative of the audience,
so complex statistical things.
We gave them an
[INAUDIBLE] of our data.
And they went away,
did some simulations
and stuff like that.
And they came back with
a statistical model,
very simple, just half
a page, simple maths.
We got it done in maybe half
an hour, just 20 lines of SQL.
I was there.
And our customers,
Telstra, was really happy.
But they wanted more.
So we gave more data
to the data scientists.
Data scientists went away,
run their simulations again.
And after three or
four months, they
came up with something like
this, like crazy complex thing.
So we were completely
lost, something
like 30 pages of
specifications, operations,
aggregations at several levels.
The way that this
model worked, it
needed to access
billions of rows
to derive these deeper insights
they wanted to get out.
And it became too complex
to be written in SQL.
And one of the things we
were actually trying to do
is being able to
have something that
could go to-- be a
maintainable product,
just raise it to
production and use it.
So we wanted to have unit
tests, write unit tests,
being able to have something
we can work and iterate on it.
And we started realizing that
we needed kind of the map
reduce style of analysis to
solve these kinds of problems.
And that's when
Dataflow came to us.
So this is actually
part of a funny story.
As part of all these
interesting adventures
we had with BigQuery, we engaged
part of the Google engineers
that worked on BigQuery.
And this is back 2014,
beginning of 2015.
Back then, Dataflow was in
alpha, early alpha access.
So they invited us to
start testing and playing
with Dataflow.
And we found that it
was really, really great
for what we needed it.
Of course now Dataflow
is in production,
generally are viable.
Just again, you probably heard
a lot about Dataflow already.
I'm just going to
quickly tell you
it's massively
parallel and scalable.
So you can run complex
operations at scale.
You see it's at a higher
level than MapReduce.
So all the stuff you
basically do with MapReduce,
imagine that you get a
high level of abstraction
with much more common
operations and you can actually
chain common things
like GROUP BY or maybe
simple transformations or
stuff like that together.
And it has a service
part and an SDK.
It's great for doing ETL.
But it is also
really, really good
for doing complex analysis.
And that's what we really needed
doing this complex-- resolving
this complex problem.
And a very interesting thing
is that it's fully managed.
Again, no worries
about infrastructure.
We didn't need to
install any Hadoop
or install or configure clusters
or do anything sort of in that.
So imagine just two developers,
just two software engineers
who can really try to do that.
And it's very cost efficient.
So we went and implemented
our model using Dataflow.
And this is how our
solution looked like.
So we still had the batch side
of the thing, the solution just
getting the logs out of DFP,
putting them in BigQuery.
And then taking advantage
of the streaming side,
we got all the
data from BigQuery.
We implement our statistical
model using Dataflow
and put all the results
back to BigQuery.
And then we were finally
able to get these insights
we were looking for.
Unfortunately I
can't really tell
you too much about this
model because it's under NDA.
So I'd really like
to tell you more,
but that's the reality of it.
And in terms of the
costs, imagine a game,
trying to manage big
clusters, having people
helping you with the
infrastructural or maybe
to set up operating system or
installing Hadoop or anything
like that.
You can't really get for
anything lower than probably,
I don't know, $30k or
something per month.
For us, it was only
$700 per month.
And we were processing
around 50 terabytes.
So let's move to a few Dataflow
tips, things we learned
when we were using Dataflow.
So a few things we found
that it's not a good idea
to try to do, you need
to be aware of long
running operations when you're
writing your transforms.
So as you might know,
transforms are actually
the atomic operations you do.
You get an input data.
You do something with the data,
and then you output the result.
And you need to be aware that
this will run multiple times.
And it will have
scaled with your data.
If you have billions
of rows and you're
trying to read from BigQuery
and you have billions of rows,
you will actually be
doing this billion time.
So if you are trying to go to
the network and do something,
that's not going
to be a good idea.
It's going to turn
out pretty slow.
It's not possible to put
everything in memory.
So if you're trying to
process two terabytes,
don't try to put in memory.
That's something
that maybe the data
scientists coming from a
completely different background
were doing.
And for us it was a challenge to
adopt the whole thing in a more
distributed way.
And Dataflow has
PCollections that
really serve for that aspect.
And another thing that you need
to be aware of is the hot keys.
The hot keys come from
a very common operation
you do with Dataflow which is,
for example, group by key where
you have a key.
And that key might have
several actual values
matching with their key,
like millions of them.
So if you see your graph and
you see your Compute instance
running, you see 203
might have very high CPU.
And the others are idle.
That means you have a hot key.
And there are
solutions for that.
I'm going to touch
about that later.
A good thing when you're
working with Dataflow
is to take advantage
of the local runner.
So Dataflow has several runners.
When you start
working with-- when
we're developing this
model, we of course
started with small data
sets and writing our program
and testing it and going
through small iterations.
And then you can actually
move to GCP runner.
So this is a good way to
deal with the hot keys.
So for example, when you need to
do something like aggregations
over these large
set of data, you
can actually use the
combine functions.
So the combine functions allow
you to basically distribute
these values that you have for
several keys into worker nodes.
And it shows Dataflow the
semantics of your program
that you're trying to implement.
So they have several steps.
You basically initialize
the accumulators.
You define accumulators
to where you
will be doing something
like, for example, summing
the values.
And then you need to
have a function that
will add each element
to the accumulators.
And then of course
you need to merge.
And then you might merge again.
And then you extract the output.
And this is how
it looks in code.
You [INAUDIBLE] from
the combine function
and specific inputs, accumulator
type and output type.
And you got there the initialize
function, the add input,
merge accumulators,
and extract outputs.
And when you want
to use it, just
basically use the combine
perKey and create an instance
of your combine function.
The composite transforms--
this is another one
that we found really useful.
So as I was telling you,
this model is pretty complex,
several aggregations,
several levels,
joins and stuff like that.
Once we actually finish
implementing the whole thing,
it was a big mess, lot
of notes connecting
each other's, company crazy.
So composite
transforms allow you
to group related operations.
And you can have something
much easier to digest.
So the way to implement is you
extend this PTransform class
and specify an input
type, output type.
And then you chain the
two transforms together.
So for example
here, we are having
an initially transform that we
put in this case a PCollection.
And then we apply a second
transform on top of it.
And we return the results.
And we went for
something like that.
And this is just a small
portion of the whole big model
to just one [INAUDIBLE].
And you can see how
much simpler it gets.
And again, I want to
reiterate, the team
was just two
engineers, just the two
of us trying to deal
with this big problem.
So at the moment,
what we're doing now
is that we're trying to
move from a batch mode,
because the model was basically
conceived in a batch mode.
The natural evolution, we
would be in a streaming mode.
So our data scientists
have taken more data
and they are running their
simulations and stuff
like that so we can actually
move to the next stage.
So just to wrap up,
Telstra was having
a lot of issues trying to
analyze all this amount of data
that they had.
By using BigQuery,
we were finally
able to allow them to
extract useful insights out
of all these amount of data.
When we were given this
very complex model,
Dataflow allows to actually
implement it in a way
that it could be maintainable
and we could iterate on it.
And using GCP gave us access
to a very powerful and scalable
infrastructure at a fraction
of the cost compared
to actually rolling out our
own infrastructure or renting
infrastructure from Telstra.
And we didn't really
need a big team.
So that's all.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]